welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of the
trailer for The Last of Us episode three
now my in-depth breakdown of the details
everyone missed in episode 2 is now on
the channel but let's look ahead to
episode three and how this show is gonna
make it even harder for me to enjoy my
Sunday night mushroom and pepperoni
pizza I mean the mushrooms I can handle
but I never want to cry while eating a
pepperoni and this Show's just so
emotional now be sure to subscribe to
our new channel the Deep dive in which I
will be doing weekly film analyzes with
a more investigatory Focus I think
you're really Gonna Love what we're
working on over there okay let's take a
look at the first half of this Last of
Us episode 3 trailer not today your new
world order Jack boot
my name's Frank here's the thing Frank
if I feed you then every bum you talk to
about it is going to show up here
looking for a free lunch
and this is not an Arby's
Harvest didn't have free lunch was a
restaurant
so this next episode is going to center
around Bill and Frank these are the
characters with whom Joel has a code
over the short range radio of 60 songs
meaning nothing new and 70s songs made
in New Stock and 80s songs meaning
trouble and since Depeche Mode's 1987
never let me down again played at the
end of episode 1. that suggested
troubled well we got trouble my friends
right here in bombed out City there's
trouble with the capital T that rhymes
with C that stands for cordyceps in the
flower Supply and the game we meet Bill
who's a grouchy survivalist who has
rigged his town of Lincoln Massachusetts
with endless deadly booby traps he's
voiced and portrayed by W Earl Brown
boom you might know from Deadwood or as
the masotogo bartender in the
Mandalorian and well I guess it would
have been fun for w or brown and Pedro
Pascal to team back up in this it just
can't be overstated how perfect of a
Cassie Joyce Nick Offerman is his iconic
role is Ron Swanson on Parks and Rec is
basically a Libertarian survivalist who
prefers living off the grid and carving
canoes quietly at home the kind of guy
you do not stop for chit chat in a lows
is there a project you're working on I
know more than you
all right but actually Offerman wasn't
the first choice Greg Mason originally
cast Khan O'Neill as Bill con O'Neill is
an excellent actor in his own right who
played the plant director in Mason's
last show Chernobyl and police chief
Bach in the Batman but O'Neill had to
drop out due to scheduling conflicts
this looks like mostly a flashback
episode showing how Bill met his partner
Frank Frank played by Murray Bartlett
the Australian actor perhaps best known
as Armand the concierge in season one of
HBO's White Lotus but here we see how
Bill has already equipped his home in
Lincoln with a paranoid bunker with
multiple security feeds which is
impressive because this infection sweeps
through the United States in a matter of
days this is a guy who is waiting for
the apocalypse to come and he was proven
right so think about who that guy is in
these security monitors if you look
closely you can see his neighbors being
Force evacuated in trucks by federal
soldiers and I love how his desktop
computer to his right is an era and
character appropriate Windows 2000 not
Windows XP that's one that had the blue
search bar along the bottom and the
Rolling Green Hills which I later found
out because I know live here is actually
Napa California Windows XP would have
been out by September 2003 but this is
the kind of guy who sticks with the old
OS because it worked just fine for him
and upgrading this how they spy on you
Frank has this legitimately great
response Arby's doesn't give out free
launches we did I mean screwed Joel's
Adkins diet I'd be on an exclusive bid
beef and cheddar diet now behind bill
for me and his carrot there is a white
church which could be the church that
bill holds up in in the game he also
wears bandolier bullets around his chest
when he catches Frank in the hole we see
Bill wearing this in the game but a big
difference from the game version of
build Nick Offerman has a far bushier
beard which you know might have just
been Offerman showing up the set saying
oh sorry I haven't shaved since
yesterday let's move on with the second
half of this trailer
sooner or later there will be Raiders
they'll come at night quiet and armed
call Joel
we'll be fine
so remember episode 2 ended with Tess
telling Joel to take Ellie to Bill and
Brinks hoping that they would take her
off his hands here it looks like they
made it the house and now Ellie looks to
be going through Bill's drawer to find a
gun beneath that a handwritten note now
in the game bill has various written
notes laid around all over the house
that you can read there are some things
going on with Bill and Frank from the
game that game players are aware of but
to protect anyone watching this show
blind from spoilers I'm Gonna Save all
the game reveals until the end of this
video and spoiler Corner as I do for All
of My Last of Us episode breakdowns it's
because I love you all and I care but
let's just quickly go through the rest
of the stuff we see in this trailer the
fact that Ellie has a gun now is
interesting because in episode two
remember she repeatedly asked for a gun
from Tess and Joel they both denied her
it doesn't look like Joel is in the room
with Ellie in this moment so Ellie May
now be carrying a secret gun he knows to
Joel this is the same kind of pistol
that Ellie does get later in the game
from the hotel and there is a whole
thing that goes down with it I was just
out of the country of my honeymoon and I
went on Netflix over there and I was
shocked to see all the stuff that
normally is there in American Netflix
but not where I was that's by it's so
important to use nordvpn with nordvpn I
can switch my virtual location on my
device with one click letting me access
streaming services from over 60
countries at no extra cost this opens up
a smorgasbord of stuff to watch that I
wouldn't be able to access without
nordvpn nordvpn is also the fastest VPN
out there so you won't have to sacrifice
speed for sake of your shows it's what
we use at new Rockstar's offices let me
tell you it's fast for the price of just
one cup of coffee a month I get to have
premium cyber security on six devices
and gain access to streaming services
from over 60 countries at no extra cost
it's also available on every platform to
grab your exclusive nordvpn deal go to
nordvpn.com new rockstars to get a huge
discount off your nordvpn plan plus a
bonus gift nordvpn is the 30-day
money-back guarantee so you can try
nordvp and completely risk-free just
click the link in the description to get
started Joel warns Bill about Raiders
and what I assume is a flashback because
behind them at the gate you can see Tess
talking to Frank so in the show's
timeline Tess and Joel had previously
visited Bill and Frank where he's in the
game only tests have gone and we see an
attack by the Raiders that Joel warned
about Bill's booby traps seem to be at
least a bit effective torching some of
the Raiders with a flamethrower the good
old Kevin McAllister method or frying
them on an electric fence which is the
Kevin McAllister method from Home Alone
2. you get pretty violent and wounded
Bill tells Frank call Joel which might
be the reason that Depeche Mode song
played in episode 1 as it was raining on
both nights but we will see this might
be an earlier incident than Joel and
Ellie on the road see some clothed
skeletons in a mass grave now for them
to be normal human skeletons this must
mean they were not infected when they
died because otherwise the fungus would
have overtaken and puppeted their
corpses so it could be these people were
straight up murdered Maybe by some gang
maybe you might deadra bummer diesel
here notice that the Skeleton on the
left is smaller this was a kid this
pairing parallels the lone wolfen Cub of
Joel and Ellie much like that shot of
the two stalks and opening credits here
a grim possible fate for these two
characters if they run into one day A
bad luck quick shot of Bill plowing has
struck their offense to some kind of
plant you go through this frame by frame
you can see he's carrying some large
bins in the back of the truck and towing
a boat I assume the bins are for fuel
that he is now going to be stealing and
hoarding but a boat very smart move
because you know that land becomes
overrun with infected it might be good
to live on a boat for a bit you never
know if these things can swim I mean
Ellie for sure can't then Ellie flips
open her mother's switchblade to poke at
this infected guy just stares her down
the Practical makeup on this series is
incredible you can see little chunks of
skin and flesh still attached to the
mycelium mycelium is the name of the
fungus tendril meaning these stalks
burst out of the guy's skin recently
Ellie seems to be looking into this
guy's eye to see if there's any Soul
left inside as she asked Joel last
episode if it was hard to kill so many
infected without thinking about the
person they used to be but the way this
guy stares her down through that
infected yellow eye we do get a sense of
some cognition the fungi seem to be
possessing collectively based on their
hive mind that this Colony shares
explained to us by Tess last episode
okay now on to spoiler corner for those
of you who have played the game or those
of you who don't care in the game Bill
and Frank were romantic Partners but we
never actually meet Frank because Frank
is dead by the time Joel brings Ellie to
Lincoln thinks that ended badly between
him and Bill Frank got sick of Bill's
survival methods and left field stealing
supplies and a car battery but then got
surrounded by a horde of infected and
got bitten several times he ended up
hanging himself leaving a pretty bitter
suicide note for Bill telling him that
he hated his guts and saying quote I
guess you were right trying to leave
this town will kill me still better than
spending another day with you yikes Joel
finds Frank's Body in this note after
searching for that military truck
battery but he gets trapped briefly by
The Horde gets hold up in a school where
you run into your first bloater in the
game bloaters were teased in episode 2
and episode 3 could be our first glimpse
of that bloater we see in the trailers
but I also wonder if that might be a
little early in the season for the
bloater I think that might be an end of
season thing ultimately this stage of
the game Joel finds the truck that that
battery was hotwired too and he and
Ellie used it to move on to Pittsburgh
but this episode on the HBO series will
finally show us what happened between
Bill and Frank whether they're still
together when Joel and Ellie arrive
maybe the couple's time together
unfolded differently then the bitter way
it was depicted in the game I thought
for a second that maybe that letter
underneath the gun that Ellie finds is
Frank's suicide note to Bill but I don't
think that would make sense like why
would he have hidden the note when he
wanted Bill to find it I just think this
letter is another one of the letters
that bill leaves lying around but by
casting interesting actors like Nick
Offerman and Murray Bartlett this shows
signals an interesting battle episode
that could give even more Dimension to
these characters than we get in the game
let me know your thoughts down below and
subscribe to the Deep dive you can
follow me on Instagram and Twitter at
hey boss follow new rockstars And
subscribe to new rockstars for more
announcements of everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]